Why is it good for the TV?Ashi and Emi
have a TV in their room, right?I'm
sure I'd like to watch TV with them, but honestly, I don't turn on the
TV that much even when I'm at home.  I do
n't have one, but I'll come. I
understand how you feel,
but
there's also the problem of the Beast God Dragon, so
how about we do something like this?
We're faced with a wall of budget,
so here's one thing we'll do is market research.  If you decide to go ahead and do some
market research, first go to a real estate agent and
find out what kind of TV contract they have.If you have to pay a bed license fee, there
is no need to talk about this.In my
apartment, all of this is included in the rent.
But don't
say too much, I don't really want to buy it, so I'm going to
listen straight to the point.Even
if the license fee issue can be cleared,
how much should the price be?I
see.
[Music]
Temporary part-time job,
we three.  Considering the income of a person,
5,000 yen per head is 15,000 yen, and the
compromise is 20,000 yen.I ca
n't afford more than that.It's only natural that
I'll spend the money, too.You should have been making the most of the money you earned on the
sea and Yamato.  You
can use it to make up for what you used
up.20,000 yen, Ashiya.Are you
forgetting one thing?
Where did you buy that refrigerator?And where did you buy the
washing machine?I'm
pretty sure I
finally noticed it at the Yodogawabashi camera at the west exit of Shinjuku.
Apparently,
he
was a research point, and when I bought it, they were in the midst of a
10% discount sale on all items.  You can
raise the upper limit to 26,239 yen, you
idiot.
Sorry, this is embarrassing. I
wanted a TV.